welcome to the global roundtable this
series focuses on the future of economic
competition i'm Parag Cunha joined by a
very distinguished panel including to
Mesa Moyo Daniel Altman and GERD hired
us
today's topic is actually the power of
language we can't be complacent anymore
in the West about controlling the
financial levers of the economy but what
about controlling the language of the
global economy which is of course
English what's the future of that
advantage for the West it's interesting
English is no longer an instrument of
soft power in the way that I think a lot
of Americans assume it is it's purely an
instrument it is an instrument for the
people who learn it to get ahead and I
think we still have a residual Cold War
idea that every time someone learns
English they like us more they like
democracy more they like our policies
there's a whole number of people in the
world today who are learning English as
a tool for getting their next promotion
we're still need to be convinced about
our values an idea doesn't it still
matter to be better at English I think
there's an economic advantage but it's
not necessarily in the quality think
about education in general when babies
are born they're born with as much
education today as they were born with a
hundred years ago or a thousand years
ago and yet you need so much more
education to get ahead in the global
economy today not having to spend extra
time learning English is an advantage
that American babies have it may not be
a big advantage but maybe it's a couple
years that they can study something else
if only we would devote more time to
something else because they aren't
unfortunately there isn't this crowding
out trade-off it's not the fact that
Americans are not spending time learning
English doesn't mean they're not
spending time doing maths and science
and if you look at the International
Organization the OECD is a piece or
survey every year the fact of the matter
is that Americans are underperforming in
mathematics in Sciences but also in
reading so I mean you have to then ask
yourself well what exactly is going on
even Chinese are learning English and
record numbers before ordering and now
after the Olympic Games which they
played host to could it really be that
countries that are not even native
english-speaking such as China and
others will actually disintermediate or
the Western sort of grip on English in
terms of jobs to disagree with Dan a bit
if you think about the u.s. or England
the UK a certain number of people within
those countries speaks a kind of English
that is globally competitive and
kind of language of global business but
most Americans and most people in
Britain don't speak in English that gets
them a job at Citibank tomorrow anyway
so I think we can over blow the number
of people who speak the kind of English
we're talking about as a language of
global business even within
english-speaking countries I think if
you make that distinction though you
start to bring in other cultural factors
there may not be people in India or
China which we are viewing as these big
threats to American dominance who are
learning the right mindset to work at
Citibank so you know we might as well
throw these other factors in some sense
as well even across African countries
people are learning Chinese and I think
there's something to be said that
because governments in Africa places
like Cameroon are actually devoting
scale relatively scarce resources to
learning Chinese over over English so we
have to ask what this trend really means
but I have to ask whether a world where
English and Chinese are the global
languages is not a world that's worse
off where there's one global language
one standard that everybody can use
isn't that an economic efficiency by
itself but I don't think we'll ever be
able to force the standardization so we
have to come to grips with the fact that
there are now multiple global languages
English and Chinese and potentially
others and beyond that English itself
isn't the only language because as you
said earlier we have to also know math
and science and those and are in a way
more Universal than English itself but
certainly language and how we define it
and use it is going to be integral to
the future of competition in the global
economy thanks very much for your
insights more on that and other relevant
topics at big thing com